okay das läuft nicht auch die mal gerade
das ist mir so was machen helfen sie mir
bitte
[Musik]
heute treffe ich kann
lebensjahr 22 jahre alt sternzeichen
widder klimaschutz aktivistin und
sprecherin von friday future in
deutschland laut faz ist sie eines der
prägenden gesichter von facebook user
und die taz zählt sie sogar zu den
wenigen ausnahmen politikerinnen unter
30 jahren bekommen hallo wie verzweifelt
ist frei der future wenn sie diese
einladung angenommen
bundesregierungen sich der klimapolitik
einem kopftor man halt einfach nichts
anderes als verzweifelt nimmt man dann
alles was man kriegen kann
sind sie jetzt eine sprechen über die
sprecherin kann man denn überhaupt
mitglied sein bike riders verfügte ohne
gleich sprecherin zu werden man kann ja
nicht mitglied werden in dem sinne ist
die frage eigentlich überflüssig ok
kritik ist angekommen
haben sie schon erfahrungen mit virtual
jetzt okay dann würde ich sagen kommt
jetzt ein herr der wird uns anziehen
[Musik]
jeder jetzt schatzsucher auf der suche
nach einem alten auto fakt nach dem
schädel aus dem amt
der befindet sich irgendwo tief im
tempel auf einem anderen planeten
es ist wo zur hölle sind wir das ist
besagter tempel
das ist eine fackel ist habe ich die
frage mit liebe die fackel ich habe erst
mal eine frage vorweg die durch corona
ist ja frei der future ein bisschen in
vergessenheit geraten können sie doch
mal kurz sagen was zu frei der s p
future ist zur erinnerung zur erinnerung
hier sind diese mit dieser kletterturm
berg haben im letzten jahr mehrere
millionen leute in deutschland auf die
straßen gebracht für klimaschutz auch
weltweit streiken die jeden freitag das
gefällt manchen konservativen politikern
nicht so gut
okay das ist freude erfüllt oder macht
gerade gar nicht klick bei mir wird es
pro monat einfach zu oft gedauert buch
was war das wie haben sie das jetzt
gemacht ja einfach meine hand
aufgehalten darum sie jetzt funktioniert
hat weiß ich nicht okay nicht und
glauben das ist jetzt ein bisschen
spießig die frage aber glauben sie die
bewegung wer genau so erfolgreich wenn
sie definitiv nicht ich glaube wir sind
ja dadurch erfolgreich geworden
aufmerksamkeit bekommen dadurch dass wir
eben gesagt habe wir brechen bewusst
diese regeln rey die klimakrise so
dringlich ist und leute auf den samstag
auf die straße gegangen für klima für
umwelt hat genau sehr wenig gebracht oft
deswegen muss man die regeln brechen
ok ich muss mir jetzt was machen ja ich
habe keine ahnung was wir schon zum
arbeiter um
ich habe eine idee ich habe eine idee
hier sind echt schönes aufgegangen
was ist passiert leichen
vielleicht einer der weißen alten männer
also alt ist auf jeden fall was war das
raten müssen raten seien das stichwort
artenvielfalt
da bin ich jetzt ich bin keine keine
umweltwissenschaftlerin bienen bienen
sind sehr wichtig also für alle verfügt
ja ist ja eigentlich jugendbewegung ja
wann sind sie zu alt für frei der future
niemand es zahl gefährlicher wir sind ja
nicht school children verfügt bin ich
gut dass wir das auch besprechen werden
hier sonst glätten kann auch gerne
mitmachen ehrlich also ja wenn das halt
freitags im stadtraum sind frauen
präsent dabei freilich computer als
männer brauchen sie vielleicht eine
männerquote euro ja ich glaube wir
brauchen unbedingt eine männerquote weil
männer haben es echt schwer im
patriarchat so ich mache mal folgendes
ich hab mal hier drauf öffnet sich die
tür jetzt ja da würde ich sagen schnell
durchrutschen und sie bleiben sie da
wenn dann müssten sie gar schneller sein
wo sind sie denn können sie mal hier ist
nämlich so ein loch in der wenn sich
immer so durchkommen ja ja ja okay wenn
sie jetzt sind wir morgen glücklich dann
hand drauf und dann rennt nicht
schneller ist das aufregend und wir sind
wieder vereint
richtig gutes team und ich sage oder sie
wollen ja den kohleausstieg bis 2030
genau ich habe das gefühl wir schauen
uns nicht mal raus hier bis 2030 wie wie
soll das funktionieren
das soll funktionieren da hat das selbst
die bundesnetzagentur der
bundesregierung hat da ganz tollen plan
aufgestellt das funktionieren kann
hier sind wir ja die habe ich jetzt okay
das läuft nicht optimal gerade helfen
sie mir bitte jetzt kriechen bisschen
panik ja ich jetzt halt zum beispiel das
brett aber ich kann halt nicht geben
ja dann das brett mit dem brett was gibt
es da zu überlegen als oder bewegen ist
kann es nicht bewegen
einfach so durch folter und den arm
waren hier stehen lassen
am board und damit sie jetzt über das
aber schaffen sie aber ich denke mir
dass sie von außen alles ganz harmlos
sieht hier schon wird's nicht aus ich
will überhaupt gar nicht wissen wie es
von außen aussieht handelt ja das darf
ich geht ja nicht in kona ich kann nur
die linke würde ich jetzt wahlen
übertragen und sabina sind hier am
abgrund klimatologische seen here raus
hier gerade jetzt motto logisch gesehen
ich glaube es nimmt sich nicht so
richtig viel zwischen hier und der
klimabilanz entwirft das pariser
klimaabkommen war ja wirklich
einzigartig in dem dass man es geschafft
hat so 193 staaten weltweit dazu zu
bringen gemeinsam das abkommen so machen
sonst gibt es sonst nicht das heißt ja
schon mal die lage ist wirklich düster
wenn sich wirklich 193 der staaten der
welt auf ein abkommen
und wenn man sieht was so politisch
passiert ist es gar nicht wenn wir uns
angucken was wirtschaftlich auch
blockiert wird bewusst weil man sagt
ortes jetzt recht unbequem da vergessen
habe ich alle leute dass es vor allen
dingen wirklich unbequem wird wenn wir
irgendwie so in zehn fünfzehn jahren die
folgen noch viel extremer spüren als wir
sie jetzt gerade schon spüren schon
jetzt sterben leute aufgrund der
klimakrise und das wird in 10 15 jahren
wird es halt eben nicht nur in staaten
in sozialer afrika in südostasien sein
sondern es wird auch noch mehr bei uns
ankommen und ich glaube dann werden sich
alle fragen hätte man nicht früher was
machen konnten und diese abgrund davor
noch gibt es die möglichkeit aber dafür
dürfte man halt nicht so eine
klimapolitik machen wie die
bundesregierung ist gerade macht
klimaschutz an allen ecken und enden
verschleppen sei es beim cola ausstieg
sei es bei der verkehrspolitik sei es
bei so was mit der abrackprämie aber
auch schon bei vergleichsweise einfachen
fragen wie wir haben ein klima kabinetts
aber keine ergebnisse
das ist verrückt haben sie das gemerkt
ich war richtig krass was ist das
ich glaube das ist irgendwas verrücktes
an dieser virtual reality feuer strich
heizstrahler ganz schlecht für die
klimabilanz machte stadler aber seid ihr
bescheuert oder was dies war zuletzt
noch lucia was sagen sie eigentlich zu
menschen die sagen wo bewegungen wie
friday the future hätten auch
antidemokratischen tendenzen
antidemokratische tendenzen ja das wird
uns sehr gerne vorgeworfen
ich frage mich woher dieser vorwurf
kommt weil tatsächlich ja das was wir
machen das demokratischste erstmal ist
erstmal die versammlungsfreiheit zu
nutzen für protest eine der wichtigsten
errungenschaften der demokratie aber vor
allen dingen fordern wir ja eine
klimapolitik im einklang mit dem 1,5
grad ziel steht und das sag ich mal die
bundesregierung deutschland 2015
unterzeichnet heißt wir fordern von der
bundesregierung nur die einhaltung eines
bereits unterschriebenen vertrags ist ja
dass demokratische dass es gibt bevor
dann ja nicht mal irgendwas was
irgendwie eine minderheit will sondern
das ist ja tatsächlich schon
unterschrieben worden
und das was die bundesregierung macht
politik zu machen die eben nicht zu
einer distanz von zwei grad ziels
beiträgt das ist vielmehr undemokratisch
weil sie sich damit ihren eigenen
parlamentarischen entscheidungen
widersetzt aber vergessen wir die
demokratie man lieber aber wir haben die
diktatur
sie sind die diktatoren welche drei
dinge würden wir als erstes ich finde
solche solche diktator sperrigen hier
ist keine schöne aufwiesen sind uns die
königin
die presse wie lieber der könig der
prinz irgendwas na gut dann sind sie
halt jetzt ist die bundeskanzlerin sie
dürfen jetzt 30 ist beschließen und
keiner sagt raus was haben sie jetzt
davon von der prinzessin zur bundes
nicht gut gelaufen
also was würden sie was konnten sie dann
als erstes ändern wollen diese frage
echt wirklich richtig er steckte ja und
ich bin echt wirklich gar nicht passt
machen sie mal politik kompatibel mit
dem einkaufen
das ziel dazu steigen wir aus der kohle
auf jalla jalla spätestens zwanzig
dreißig aber im besten fall noch früher
wir fördern die erneuerbaren so sehr
dass wir sogar unser selbst gesteckten
ziele die wir gerade nicht einhalten
dass wir die übertreffen und bis 20.35
komplett erneuerbare energien haben in
deutschland und dann für den co2 preis
einen der tatsächlich den kosten
entspricht die co2 dieses engagement ist
jetzt 33 kohleausstieg erneuerbare
energien und das dritte ist der co2
preis den tatsächlichen kosten
entspricht weil jede tonne co2 kostet
meine generation 180 euro deshalb führen
wir einen schrittweise sozial gerecht
und ich glaube dann haben wir eine ganz
okay man dort für einen guten ersten
richtigen schritte nicht überblick
dreieck erste richtige schritt
ok also ich würde ja gern zu den
diamanten zurück wenn sie schon nicht
wollen dann will ich also ich sage mal
wir gehen mal hier so drauf jetzt haben
sie den salat jetzt fliegen sie doch ich
glaube ich kann es mir klima touristen
sind dafür totenschädel den gefangen
sollten glaube ich hab's geschafft das
beste aus kohlenstoff machen kann sind
diamanten oder es wird sie auch sagen ob
das natürlich hätten richtig gute
zweitverwertung das ist ein richtiger
fdp gehen wir nehmen das co2 aus der
luft kommen passieren ist so sehr ich
schenke den slogan lasst uns diamanten
machen und ich bin jetzt gerade voll
grünlich ich spüre vor der future spüre
es werden wir hier fliegen gezahlt die
musik der zwei sich das jetzt alles was
daten
[Musik]
was sie sehen ja noch gut aus beim
schwitzen nicht die werbung hat er gar
nicht irgendwas hat sich jetzt mehr
beeindruckt die virtuelle realität oder
die begegnung mit einem tv star und die
gespräche von mir für die kamera das
natürlich bietet nun mit ihnen heute
show ist natürlich bekanntlich bei
jungen leuten schon auch ein großes
großes ding sie inklusive
obwohl glaube ich glaube ihre twitter
redakteure sind mindestens genauso
berühmt und beliebt wie sie auch wenn
jemand weitere das ist also in einer
virtuellen religion haben wir noch ein
fazit irgendwas was ihnen auf dem herzen
ich glaube wenn die bundesregierung und
die politischen entscheidungsträger alle
so innovativ werden wie die leute die
das wir entwickelt haben
dann können unsere welt ganz anders
aussehen sie muss ja nicht voll sein
voller diamanten nicht aber darauf
können wir uns einigen aber der wandel
wäre vielleicht ein bisschen schneller
schöner punkt
ein schneller wandel aber von mir aus
mit ganz vielen schönen diamanten und
damit vielen dank ich mache mich jetzt
mal hier wieder trocken ist echt
ekelhaft dass sie das überhaupt ertragen
getragen
hallo hier spricht zukunfts lutz du
wirst dich in spätestens einer woche
darüber geärgert haben nicht den kanal
der heute-show abonniert zu haben also
tue es neben mir findest du videos die
duh interessant und lustig gefunden
haben wirst gefunden haben wirst es foto
das klingt ja wohl total dämlich